we were always told that milk is good
for our bones that carbohydrates make us
fat that eggs are bad for us and that we
should always buy organic food what have
we told you that this is all a huge myth
stay tuned to find out the real truth
about pineapples if you're new here hit
that subscribe button to never miss
another video and don't forget to give
us a big thumbs up now let's debunk some
food myths carbohydrates make you fat
let's start with a myth that's often
practiced by people in the fitness
industry carbohydrates always get a bad
reputation and are always a topic that
sparked some interesting debate when it
comes to weight loss the truth is eating
carbohydrates will not make you fat as
they're essential to our diets the myth
first appeared in the popular Atkins
diet which is known to focus on eating
low carbs to achieve weight loss however
carbohydrates come from a broad category
of macronutrients and you can find many
types of carbs in our diets these
include sugar starch and fiber and the
quantity and quality of each has a
different effect on your weight gain or
weight loss for example you should
always consume enough carbohydrates
which include fiber to maintain a
healthy digestive system and metabolism
cutting out carbohydrates from your diet
can result in a nutritional deficiency
if you fail to substitute them with
alternatives by completely replacing
carbohydrates with fats can increase the
amount of cholesterol in your body and
put you at risk of heart disease
so while carbohydrates don't make you
fat you should always balance it out
with other nutritional foods it's
recommended that at least one-third of
our diet includes carbohydrates and
these come from any starchy foods such
as potatoes bread rice and pasta balance
them with fruits vegetables and protein
and you're guaranteed to reach your
long-term health goals microwaving
destroys the nutrients you've probably
heard of this one before some people
claim that the radiation from the
microwave can completely destroy the
nutritional and health benefits of
cooked food the truth is it's completely
safe for you to cook food in a microwave
since it uses less heat than any other
conventional cooking method for now
University did a study of some of the
most water-soluble vitamins like
folic acid vitamins B and C to see the
effects the microwave heat has on
nutritional benefits according to the
studies the spinach which was cooked in
a microwave retains nearly all of its
vitamin B but lost 77% of the
nutritional benefits when cooked on a
stove they also discovered that
conventionally cooked bacon has higher
levels of cancer-causing chemical
compounds than bacon cooked in a
microwave it's also been reported that
adding water to cook vegetables can
cause a significant loss of antioxidants
as opposed to cooking vegetables in a
microwave in some cases using a
microwave can even enhance the nutrition
of food if you microwave carrots and
tomatoes you're enhancing the red
pigmentation that protects our health if
you microwave eggs you're also making
the vitamin H more digestible and speed
up the conversion of food into energy so
go on microwave your food we promise
your health won't be affected by it
peanuts grow on trees but it's not all
about nutrition in this video we'll also
debunk some myths about where your food
actually comes from keep on watching to
learn a surprising fact about pineapples
but first let's debunk the belief that
peanuts are grown on trees just like any
other nuts out there
unlike walnuts or pecans peanuts don't
actually grow on trees in fact it's
quite surprising to find out they're a
part of the legume family where you can
also find beans lentils and peas
this also means if they grow from
underground they might look like regular
18-inch plants with oval-shaped leaves
but under the ground these plants
actually develop their fruits in this
case peanuts the growing cycle of
peanuts also significantly
differentiates from other nuts it takes
five to seven years to grow a walnut
tree before it's suitable for harvesting
meanwhile peanuts can be planted and
harvested in just four to five months
peanut plants also develop yellow
looking flowers forty days after the
initial plantation once the pebbles fall
off and the plant begins to form a stem
which results in a peanut it's ready to
be harvested then they get dried for two
or three days stored and placed on
peanut Baggins this is what a field full
of peanut plants actually looks like
there are no nut trees in sight you can
detox your body with the rising
popularity of juice
there are now millions of detox diet
plans available that claim they help you
reach your weight loss goals the truth
is those plans are largely a selling
scam you don't need to detox your body
to reset it as it has its own
detoxification functions you don't need
any cleanses or special products that
will help you get rid of bodily toxins
here's how your liver is the best detox
tool for your body your liver is
powerful enough to prevent viruses from
entering your bloodstream and it filters
any sort of environmental toxins and
excess nitrogen your kidneys also hold a
powerful function by removing extra
toxins and excess water from your blood
these processes are happening every
single day and are powerful on their own
so why does juicing or doing a body
cleanse actually help you lose weight
the answer is pretty simple it's because
you're not eating not because any actual
detox is happening in your body the lack
of fiber along with the caloric and
nutritional intake from detox diets
could also lead to fatigue dizziness and
serious muscle tissue breakdown in the
long term all you have to do is eat a
balanced diet and let your liver and
kidneys do the rest skipping breakfast
contributes to weight loss breakfast is
the most important meal of the day but
diets like paleo claim that skipping
breakfast contributes to weight loss and
a healthier lifestyle at the same time
breakfast has also been highlighted as
one of the most contributing meals when
it comes to weight loss the truth is
breakfast alone will have very little
effect on your weight loss however
studies which looked at data of
thousands of people who have lost weight
and kept it off for at least a year show
that 80 percent of people reported
regularly eating breakfast to achieve
their goals there is no reported
difference between the energy intake and
those who eat breakfast and those who
prefer to skip it to reach their weight
loss goals however it has been reported
that consuming food early in the morning
gave people a slightly better advantage
when it came to increase physical
activity this theory was confirmed by a
four-month long high-quality study that
reported absolutely no health difference
between people who eat breakfast and
those who don't the truth is our bodies
produce a hormone called cortisol which
maintains our blood sugars as we wake up
this is also a reason why some of us
never get hungry first thing in the
morning
and that's completely okay so if you're
used to skipping breakfast you can
continue to do so and if not keep
enjoying it never use wooden cutting
boards with meat you might not pay
attention to this food myth if you're
not a big cook but if you're a huge
foodie you've probably heard that you
should never use wooden cutting boards
with meat some believe that wooden
cutting boards contain more bacteria
than plastic boards as those are easier
to be Queens however food scientists
debunked this myth and noted there's no
antibacterial benefits to using a
plastic board over a wooden one you've
probably seen plastic boards advertised
as antibacterial before right the truth
is that's just another marketing scam
that doesn't hold much value a food
researcher tested this theory with ten
wooden cutting boards and 14 different
plastic polymers and came to a
conclusion that neither is more
preventive than the other rather than
purchasing a specific material to make
sure your food is bacteria free you
should always make sure you disinfect
the cutting board after each use however
there is a benefit to plastic cutting
boards over solid wood you can easily
stick the plastic ones in a dishwasher
while the wooden board might crack open
which makes it even harder to clean to
disinfect the boards use a sanitizing
solution like chlorine bleach and then
rinse with water this is also
recommended to keep the meat and
vegetables on separate cutting boards to
avoid cross-contamination milk is good
for healthy bones drinking milk will
keep your bones strong
if you've ever purchased a milk carton
you know the message is frequently
displayed on every product that claims
it's full of calcium we are told that
drinking milk is extremely important for
healthy bones throughout our childhood
but just how much truth is there to that
statement the claim largely comes from a
marketing strategy which is exactly why
you can find this supposed benefit
mentions directly on a dairy products
like milk but recent studies which
collected data from over 100 thousand
milk drinking men
women suggested that there aren't any
reports showing Derry is actually
responsible for stronger bones while
it's true that calcium is responsible
for keeping our bones healthy and strong
consuming dairy like milk can cause many
other health problems that negate the
initial benefit drinking milk has also
been a subject of frequent causes of
lactose intolerance as scientists point
out that the amount of sugar protein and
essentially lactose make it harder for
us to digest the elements and cause
metabolism issues you can also receive
an equivalent calcium dosage along with
plenty other nutritional benefits if you
consume enough dark leafy greens salmon
tuna catfish almond butter and cheese
alternatives to milk such as nut or rice
milk are also highly recommended for
those who find it extremely hard to
digest regular cow's milk eating eggs
will increase your cholesterol levels
how do you like your eggs poached
scrambled or sunny-side up how many of
you have stopped eating eggs after you
heard that they could increase your
cholesterol levels and put you in a
bigger risk of heart disease a study
with over 100,000 people found that up
to one egg per day is not associated
with increased heart disease risks and
individuals who are already consuming a
healthy diet and although eggs are
actually high in cholesterol they come
with plenty of nutritional benefits they
may help lower the risk of heart disease
eggs also come with a very low amount of
mono saturated and polyunsaturated fat
which is still healthier than some of
the other types on top of that it has
been reported that dietary cholesterol
and cholesterol found in blood are only
weakly related it's pretty safe to
assume that unless you eat two eggs for
breakfast every single day enjoying eggs
in the morning will not put you in any
kind of health risk the research
conducted also showed that for most
people the mix of consumed fats from
other foods still had a bigger effect on
blood levels than a regular egg
consumption
so go ahead treat yourself to some eggs
in the morning you can make them even
healthier by not frying them in butter
and try and a poached egg recipe instead
organic food is healthy organic is a
label you often see
various foods it's automatically assumed
that your food is healthy and high
quality but that's not always the case
in fact the word organic has often been
considered as a marketing fad that
tricks people into buying unnecessarily
expensive food items eating organic food
won't make you healthier if you consume
organic snacks like cookies chips are
any kind of candy it still holds the
same amount of sugar back and empty
calories that add to weight gain studies
have also found that there are no
reported nutritional differences between
eating organic and non-organic food when
it comes to animals being raised
organically studies have also reported
no significant differences between pigs
raised on conventional or organic farms
in fact pigs who had access to larger
open areas were more exposed to their
load of parasites pathogens and
predators and yet a Nielsen studies show
that more than 50% of consumers are
willing to purchase organic if it meant
avoiding toxins while scientists are
still unsure whether organic food comes
from any real benefits one thing is for
certain organic farms still hold plenty
of environmental benefits and build a
healthy land so while the food might not
be healthier for you it's definitely
healthier for the planet pineapples grow
on trees do you know where pineapples
actually come from a common belief is
that you can find and harvest pineapples
from trees but that is completely Foss
Google a pineapple tree and see what
this so-called tree actually looks like
the delicious fruit grows on the ground
and comes from a leafy plant and looks
pretty awesome this dam is surrounded by
sword-like weaves which grow up to five
feet which is very impressive once the
plant starts growing flowers those
flowers produce a single fruit known as
a pineapple and did you know pineapples
aren't really grown from seeds after you
pick a ripe pineapple the mother plant
will produce a sucker also known as a
ratoon from the main stem that can
easily produce new plants if we planted
you can move these suckers to a new pot
and they'll become a mother plant
however unlike the original pineapple
flower the suckers are only able to
produce a single pineapple fruit how
awesome is that
one mother plants can fruit three times
during their
time before it has to be replanted
although the edible quality of the last
pineapple will probably decrease the
entire plantation process can take up to
two years and the best part is you can
totally plant pineapples indoors
suddenly we really want to plant our own
pineapples that's it for 10 myths about
food you still believe for more videos
like this one check out 10 foods you'll
never buy again after knowing how they
are made see you next time